hi guys I'm Greg time John so I was on
collider right now and apparently the
first thor ragnarok synopsis an image
has been revealed oh boy John let's read
this John haven't read this yet I
skimmed through it a little bit in
Marvel Studios thor ragnarok thor is in
prison on the other side of the universe
without his mighty hammer man and it
finds himself in a race against time to
get back to ask our staff will stop
ragnarök the destruction of his
homeworld in the end of the Asgardians
civilization oh man the hands of an all
new powerful threat the ruthless hela
but first he must survive a deadly
gladiator contest gladiatorial contests
that pits him against his former ally of
fellow Avenger The Incredible Hulk ooh
[Music]
that's a pretty cool plot description
yeah me I'm from pretty cool I don't
know much about Marvel comic like the
actual source material especially Thor
from brief understanding of gathering
bits and pieces over articles over time
that Ragnarok and like mythology like
led to the destruction of like Thor and
Odin I heard that in the comics though
he's kind of like a clone of Thor that
Tony Stark invented wait is Ragnarok an
actual guy or is wrecked like this
minute sound like Ragnarok is like Anna
pot the name of an apocalypse [ __ ] yeah
yeah that exactly and because that's
what it's like it would the mythology
Ragnarok is the end times yeah yeah
exactly but then in the comics he's like
a cyborg clone the order goes missing in
the comics and then he gets recreated by
tony stark and richard reid interest and
so but it doesn't sound like it's going
for that it sounds like it's going just
for the mythology aspect of it i'll feel
like they're actually including the
character maybe haven't read enough
about it perfect opportunity for a cross
over there seen its Ragnar off with the
actual villainous Gila and he loves like
the goddess of death from when I've
gathered I'm really hoping that they do
a great job with this villain because
Thor introduced Loki and I Loki was an
amazing bill until he got to Avengers
movie no one even remembers the [ __ ]
second villain really was unless you're
actually big I remember because I love
Chris
for Eccleston what's his name the actor
the character is an elf is something you
don't know the characters do this the
thing is I look back on that movie and
I'm like I know I fully acknowledge I
only remember you because of who played
you but I think when everyone's gonna
get really excited something tells me
the promotional aspect is gonna focus
more on this flight that he's gonna have
to have against the Hulk you know
they've had they've had their captain
america vs civil war verse another
Captain America versus Iron Man in civil
war and now they're gonna happen I feel
like they're really gonna promo Thor in
the whole going toe-to-toe yeah and I
think that's a cool thing for both of
these franchises because you know it
seems like most people would agree that
Thor could be better yeah as a series I
think we're getting to a point now where
most people are like well if we have the
Marvel Universe why don't we have a Hulk
movie and doing a vs movie like this at
least is what it sounds like is a good
way to do both of those things at the
same time like send Thor off in a
confident direction and spark up a new
direction yeah the hulk and cate
blanchett she's gonna be playing the
villain and cape launched its always
she's a great action she's not always
like just depending on the role she gets
in the amount of screen time she gets
don't buy two gin she gets enough screen
time she does great cheap why oh yeah
any a Jones for ya and Tom Hiddleston is
coming back you know like he hasn't been
in the film since I think thor the dark
world so that's pretty awesome he's done
some smaller stuff he did he did high
rise which was a sci-fi movie I really
wanted to see you know has done anything
else in a hank williams movie and I call
movie Oh are you joking with me right
now Tom Hiddleston yeah yeah he's in
Kong Skull Island no no I know but were
you joking about him not doing anything
since Thor to know I was saying that
hasn't been low key since Thor 2 oh yeah
so they cut out his appearance in age of
Ultron but he is low key in Kong's Goa
and Jeff Goldblum was gonna be in this
forgot who is playing and Karl Urban's
gonna be in just wait Jeff Goldblum and
Karl Urban are going to be in Thor
Wagner yeah wow that's cool yeah i like
both of those guys all over supposed to
play a villain as well some as guardian
warrior Jeff Goldblum I think he's gonna
be like the guy who's like kind of in
charge of the matches in some way please
call like the Grandmaster you know be
great making notes before we film these
videos there I mean you know the off the
cuff we had to play the cuff this adds a
flavor but it
notice Laden or rich comments you know
yes preparation is key this is cool
casting information me because I'm
really intrigued by this movie and some
of the time if you said Jeff Goldblum is
gonna be in the new thora I would be
like ah but because of a the other
people who are around and because of at
least my experience of the director I
feel like this could turn out really
cool and quirky and distinct feeling
they're actually going for an
intentionally fun vibe this time yeah
something tells me the marketing might
have like a serious trailer or two but I
feel like they're gonna have like a
really fun trailer which would be a nice
new touch 4th or because the first floor
like had humor in it but the trailers
are very serious thor the dark world try
being more than what it actually was and
this one I feel like they're going for a
lot more fun elements like this sounds
like a badass fun time destruction of
asgaard a threat but then you got this
like storyline bar from the planet hulk
comics where Hulk is like a gladiator in
space or some [ __ ] like that like he
actually competes and matches and stuff
I think it's gonna be awesome and I feel
like the first footage of that is just
gonna get us jacked up to see Thor and
Hulk going toe-to-toe like an awesome
light or match with the crowd watching
and everything yeah and like isn't even
the gladiator master kind of being put
in a position where you have to kill a
baby for will die and then the Hulk will
take over the ranch guts or the Hulk
we'll just agree to go to do yeah
whatever the current and moving forward
phase is does seem like I'm intrigued by
everything right now because they've
made some you know confident decisions
and they've made some actual tone shifts
at least so yeah I like their interest
in evolution and this sounds like a lot
of fun and it sounds like we might get
to see a different version of Hulk than
you would normally in the Avengers
universe Oh totally and a Baeza to
primarily be at Hulk form and and the
thing is like I'm sure there will be you
know a little bit of dark you know in
the trailers but like I feel like as
long as they're true to Thor that's okay
a guy like Tycho itd can really drum up
the comedy and make it more likable as a
movie yeah but I don't think he's gonna
lose you know the stakes of Thor's is
the plot of this sounds like a really
fun exciting good time yeah I know yeah
it sounds like an epic you know space
movie it's okay so this is
one of based fantasy film that sounds
awesome dude of all the upcoming marbles
this is what I'm like yeah I want to
succeed Deb let's do this I'm definitely
exciting this is cool because I'm really
excited for a marble phone without
haven't even seen a trailer they have
this first image up here not sure what
we're getting in this image that must be
Beulah I mean it looks you know Tolkien
e goes Norse mythology you know well I
mean that's the cool thing about the the
genre that is Thor is like I feel like
as they move forward they can make Thor
even more of a fantasy epic you know
bringing that Lord of the Rings Flair
that you know old old school mythology
flare just like I only see lower legs
cuz that image looks like those designs
you know bringing that FLIR even heavier
into the Thor world is something that
intrigues me because yeah it's more
flavor it's different yeah I really hope
they're amping up the epic fantasy with
it back with a lot of comic yeah yeah
back with a lot of like work a place
Lord of the Rings you know what is it
like part of the the charm of the first
Thor movie is the fish-out-of-water
comedy yeah and and I feel like keeping
that element in Thor is like that that
sketch they made was so funny I thought
it was really funny yeah I think so too
cuz it's all him being a fish out of
water but now he's just really into
Italy yeah I feel like Bruce Banner
might get more of that came her this
time around because you know he's a
human that's gonna be really cool to see
that him in there yeah I think like they
pairing up the whole game now that's a
great memory excited for I really like
Marvel movies what do you guys think it
feel a Ragnarok you're new to the
channel subscribe today John raises
Jerry on Twitter Instagram social media
manager or Facebook and gloom houses of
real rejects please subscribe it would
make me feel good to know that you're in
me what